après cinquante ans de mariage entre le
royaume uni et l'union européenne
l'heure est au divorce mais ce divorce
prend du temps c'est en principe le 31
décembre prochain que le bref si tu dois
prendre effet problème aucun accord n'a
pour le moment été trouvé et la fermeté
du négociateur britannique david frost
dans une interview à l'hebdomadaire mail
on sunday n'est pas pour faciliter les
choses
nous ne serons pas un état vassal nous
n'allons pas accepter des clauses qui
donnerait à bruxelles le contrôle sur
notre monnaie ou sur notre façon
d'organiser les choses ici au royaume
uni et ça ne devrait pas être sujet à
polémique
c'est ce qui signifie être un pays
indépendant c'est ce pourquoi le peuple
britannique a voté et c'est ce qui se
produira à la fin de l'année quoi qu'il
arrive ces annonces contrarie les plans
du négociateur en chef européen michel
barnier
selon lui le royaume uni ne veut pas
d'accord sur la pêche pour exclure les
pêcheurs européens des eaux britanniques
le gouvernement britannique cherche
toujours à conserver les avantages de
l'ua et du marché unique sans les
obligations without d'obligations de yu
a lieu a fait preuve à plusieurs
reprises de flexibilité et de créativité
pour travailler avec les lignes rouges
du royaume uni sur le rôle de la cour de
justice européenne par exemple sur la
préservation de l'autonomie législative
du royaume uni en matière de pêche
il est temps que le royaume uni fassent
de même will moore être clair nous ne
sacrifierons jamais les intérêts
économiques et politiques à long terme
de lieu au seul profit du royaume uni
pour de sol benefit o2 uk
si d'ici à mardi aucun accord n'est
trouvé les européens craignent un échec
des négociations et une sortie sans
accord en cas de brick si dur seules les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce s'imposerait avec à la clé des
droits de douane élevés et des contrôles
douaniers poussé pour les entreprises
déjà les sociétés de poids lourd
britannique anticipe un blocage à
l'entrée dû tunnel sous la manche
des règles plus strictes pour et peu
c'est davantage sur les relations
commerciales du royaume uni avec ses
partenaires eux aussi très touchée par
la crise du congo navires us